[Applause]
[Music]
how did bernie madoff manage to swindle
billions from the richest to most
powerful people on wall street we are
talking about the biggest pyramid scheme
of all time a story that has all the
ingredients of a novel or a good
screenplay luxury money wealth rags to
riches a lot of secret dealings and a
sudden fall into the abyss when the
house of cards collapsed with the
outbreak of the financial crisis of
2008.
so the protagonist of this particular
story is bernie lawrence madoff bernie
to his friends madoff was a well-known
american financier who managed to gain
the trust of the most reputable
investors funds and investment banks on
wall street madoff had the financial
elite in his pocket couldn't be better
set but also people as rich and
prominent as steven spielberg kevin
bacon pedro almadoba or alicia koplovich
among many others for almost two decades
he even managed to completely bypass the
powerful u.s stock market regulators
without them ever having the slightest
suspicion
[Music]
i remember that we're not talking about
a minor matter it is estimated that the
pyramid model set up by bernie madoff
ended up voluntizing more than 65
billion dollars from the accounts of his
clients just try to process that figure
yes yes your ears don't deceive you 65
billion with a b it was perhaps the
biggest wall street scam ever and of
course the story didn't end well after
the whole operation was uncovered madoff
was arrested at the end of 2008 on 11th
of december just a year later in 2009 he
was sentenced to 150 years in prison he
died in prison on the 14th of april 2021
swindler bernie madoff creator of the
biggest ponzi scheme in history dies in
prison
[Applause]
now how could this character set up a
whole pyramid structure in the very
heart of wall street how far did the
implications of this gigantic scam reach
in this video that we've made along with
our friends from value school we tell
you all the details
[Music]
the pyramid that collapsed
after the scandal was uncovered victims
began to emerge from all sides the main
victims were the fairfield century fund
limited which had 7.3 billion in
madoff's account and the kinggate global
fund limited with 2.8 billion the
earthquake was plain and simple huge
both inside and outside the united
states the major firms operated with
madoff american banks and foreign banks
as important as credit aggregate bnp
paribas nomura and hsbc which held
positions for almost 1.5 billion dollars
in a single country such as spain the
commission that regulates the securities
market estimated that the madoff scheme
could have caused losses of up to three
billion euros this was largely due to
the fact that the santander group
managed more than 2.3 billion euros
linked to madoff's products through the
optimal fund a hedge fund domiciled in
switzerland an operation that had
multi-billion dollar repercussions
18th of march 2019 santander customers
swindled by bernard madoff get their
money back this monday santander decided
in 2009 to restore the principal
invested to private banking clients
affected by the scam resulting in 1.38
billion euros
[Music]
huge spanish fortunes such as porcelain
king jose ladro and transportation
dynasty the fernandez samosa family
among others signed up to the fund in
fact spain was the second hardest hit
country by the scam after the united
states of course there are always those
who lose more and those who lose less
[Music]
according to the wall street journal
carl shapiro once known as the cotton
king of new york city and a friend of
madoff's for 50 years may have been the
individual who suffered the most losses
as much as 545 million dollars of course
others also accused him of making a
fortune over the years thanks to the
income received from the contributions
made by new clients
[Music]
anyway however it happened the question
on our minds is how on earth did this
system really work well you see through
his investment firm which operated as a
real financial group with its own
investment advisory and even its own
broker madoff's operations followed the
classic pyramid scheme that is he
promised great returns to his clients
they were not paid out from the return
on the investments which in reality were
mostly fictitious but with the funds
contributed by new clients a textbook
ponzi scheme bernie madoff had set up a
business that was not really a business
at all the profits he brought to his
clients with returns ranging from 8 to
12 regardless of what was happening in
the stock market not come from real
operations but from the contributions of
new clients in other words the income
from the new customers was used to pay
the yields of the old ones a system that
in order to work successfully required
two absolutely necessary conditions
now let me explain the first essential
factor was to get a constant stream of
new clients coming in with more and more
fresh money something that prior to the
bursting of the real estate bubble and
the subsequent financial crisis was not
that difficult to achieve you know these
were the financial years of economic and
financial bonanza money flowed happily
and many investors and citizens risked
their wealth without too much fear in
short there were plenty of clients the
second condition was that not all
clients could request to withdraw their
funds at the same time because if they
did the pyramid would quickly collapse
and the jig would be up but of course
with returns as high as those promised
by madoff who would want to withdraw
their money from such a golden goose
the collapse and bankruptcy of the
lehman brothers however changed
everything suddenly fear gripped the
markets and investors either needed
their funds back or were scrambling to
put their money somewhere safe and at
that very moment after receiving
requests for refunds from his clients
for more than seven billion dollars that
he did not have he admitted to his
children and some of his employees the
double business that he'd been doing for
years and then absolutely unable to meet
all the commitments madoff was forced to
declare bankruptcy the chaos surprise
and stupifaction was almost universal
but how was he able to build a pyramid
of almost 65 billion us dollars without
anyone investors regulators or the
median noticing anything unusual well in
order to answer that question we have to
start the story at the very very
beginning
the promise of constant profitability
bernie madoff was a well-respected
figure in new york and are highly
regarded in financial circles from the
time that he started his investment
company madoff investment securities in
the 1960s after failing to complete his
law studies a company that by the way he
started with only five thousand dollars
that he managed to accumulate working as
a lifeguard and sprinkler installer in
the beginning he worked with penny
stocks that is low value shares if
you've ever seen the wolf of wall street
you will know exactly what i'm talking
about the fact is that his activity was
escalating and with it his fame and his
position this makes sense because at the
beginning things went smoothly and at
full sail thanks to the contacts that he
forged over time and his management
style he was able to manage the money of
large fortunes and large companies we
might even say that for many years
having your money under the management
of bernie madoff was a source of
prestige his usual mode of operation was
known as split strike conversions a
method that uses an index of options the
operation is broadly as follows a
manager buys the shares of an index
through options that are also listed and
thereafter buys and sells these options
against the shares of the same index
[Music]
however in view of his enormous success
as he himself acknowledged madoff
stopped trading actual stocks in the
1990s and switched to pretending to do
so then he would introduce fake
securities in his clients portfolios and
from there he would take the historical
profitability let's say that he first
decided what returns he wanted to give
his clients and then from there invented
a portfolio that made sense with those
returns
[Music]
of course no one really wanted to know
about it after all madoff seemed to be
achieving returns above even the market
and even more surprisingly with very
little variability regardless of what
the stock market did to give you an idea
their investments suffered only five
months of declines between 1993 and 2007
and the average real return throughout
all of those years was eight percent
[Music]
and not only that his investment firm
together with five other large companies
even founded the nasdaq the emblematic
index of wall street's technological
sector of which he later became chairman
for three years under his mandate he
attracted companies such as apple sun
microsystem cisco and google and later
he became a member of advisory
committees for the sec the stock market
regulator that was theoretically in
charge of supervising and controlling
their businesses he was also a regular
charity fundraiser and made significant
contributions to the democratic party
in other words he was clearly one of the
great wall street kingpins everyone
trusted bernie madoff and even when
someone dared to question his incredible
returns the american financier always
came out on top this was the case for
example with financial analyst harry
marco polos who collected evidence and
time and time again proclaimed that
madoff's figures were simply impossible
to obtain he got hold of confidential
documentation tested the strategy and
even with the help of quantitative
analysts demonstrated that there was no
correlation between madoff's profits and
the performance of the s p 100. thus
filing a formal complaint with the sec
but nothing came of it don't even think
that this was an isolated event the
truth is that starting in the 90s the
sec regulators investigated the
financial scheme that was actually a
gigantic pyramid of up to five times
they never detected anything therefore
when everything came to light there was
general astonishment
[Applause]
and the consequences thousands of
investors lost significant amounts of
money madoff who had managed to amass a
personal fortune of 650 million dollars
ended his days in a jail cell and the
sec and us authorities took steps to
tighten regulation they even published
the investors decalogue i'll leave it in
the description in case you want to take
a look at it and there you have it the
story of one of the greatest frauds in
the history of world finance the
greatest financial pyramid of all time
with apologies to some social security
systems but now the question is over to
you how do you think such a pyramid scam
could be set up without anyone knowing
anything about it have you ever been
promised safe extraordinarily high and
constant returns over time please leave
your comments below and now if you found
this video interesting don't forget to
like and subscribe to visualpolitik all
the best see you next time
you